[Music]
so if you could please just say you're a
full name into the microphone my name is
bob sumner that's my full name bob
sumner welcome to hot breath it's nice
to be here
how breath lean off I really appreciate
you taking the time to do this seriously
I know how valuable your time is and I
was so happy to not only be able to
perform on your show but then you'd be
willing to actually sit down with me so
that's that's what it's all about me
yes all about us coming together and
make [ __ ] work yeah
simple as that well you know how to do
that you got a little bit of a track
record a little bit so what is this what
does this show we're shooting right now
for laughs Bob what is this this is a
new creation that we've come up with a
couple guys in my office who's been
working with me for a number of years
Jamal they do who's actually the
director along with Rebecca Hayes and
the producer Carlos Costas we had some
audio we had some material that was just
on the shelf these guys decide that
they're gonna like try something and
what they're gonna do is they're gonna
take this audio and take some of the
stand-up comedy that you can actually
visualize and pretty much give you a
comedy video so they tried it out sent
it over to me and when I looked at it I
was like wow this is crazy
and we dropped this video on YouTube
with the comedian by the name of red
grant he does this bit called Froot
Loops you know about kids not being able
to uh you know eat Froot Loops in the
house following with it or whatever and
I mean this thing we received like over
50 million views I think it's probably
closer to with shares and stuff maybe a
hundred but then we you know they we
came up with more and more these guys
just started putting it all together
next thing you know the network's come
calling and truTV
they want out you know and this is
getting ready to be a eight it's gonna
be sick it's gonna be bigger than my
previous hey oh yeah Def Jam but what
what makes you think this is gonna be
such a hit what about it because it
hasn't been done for one I mean it
really hasn't been done I mean people
talk about drunk history and things like
that there's a little similarity to it
but not really even I'm I could I would
say when I say he hasn't been done it
kind of have been done early Charlie
Chaplin kind of did it seriously I mean
when you think about silent movie you
you took a silent movie and then you had
the you know the words on the screen and
then you had the Chaplin or whoever you
know playing everything out you know
what's his name Arbuckle he was even not
fatty-fatty Arbuckle
he was another silent movie star little
history there but what what they would
do is act out scenes and then you would
see the words right mm-hmm with this the
comedians are actually giving you their
stand up stories beginning middles and
in all right and you know there are a
lot of comedians who when they tell the
story you can actually visualize it but
you just see them onstage you don't
really see it with this show you will
see the actual joke come to life it's
like if you take a song you take a song
and it and you turn it into a music
video we've taken a joke
and if turned it into a comedy video
it's as simple as that man and when I
say that laughs mobs laugh tracks hosted
by cypher sounds is the next big thing
it's the next big thing well you've been
on you've done radio you've done TV what
do you think is the next like wave are
you still a do you think TV is still the
ITER's the Internet is kind of wet
the internet seems to be the way to go
at least a lot of stand-up comedians or
I shouldn't even call them stand-ups a
lot of YouTube comedians are winning
right now yeah
because of the internet you know I mean
I am NOT a big fan of you know watching
videos on you know comedians on videos
I'd like to see the live show you know I
mean but it's working for them because
it seems to me that a lot of people are
looking for how many viewers do you have
and I mean it even went for us with this
TV show yeah I'm like well okay oxymoron
yeah what do you think is I mean just
thinking in terms of technology and how
it is affecting comedy and you you did
Def Jam
I guess you said your first project that
your first success Def Jam oh yeah yeah
and that was before social media before
social media so you you've I've heard
you reference that there's like a
formula you like a great show what are
what are some of the recipes there well
I don't worry I mean my my my formula is
my formulas I really don't you know I
don't I don't really give away my formal
I'm a grandmother made these roles in
gingerbread only a couple of us at that
formula so I mean there is a formula but
it's it's yours right everybody has
their own like my eye is my eye you know
I see people get on who I pass on then I
see you know people who I put on that
other people wasn't checking until I
started checking for you know and they
win most of the time so you know it's
really like a it factor these two nights
that I've been down here in Atlanta
looking at Talent
some people have been okay some people
have been great some people some people
you know but uh but at times right but
at the same time
speaking of law of averages for me if I
see one or two out of ten that's great
because at the
today I'm looking for maybe 80 84 jokes
so if I'm gonna go to 20 cities and I
see you know three or four people that I
liked and all of them have you know a
joke or two or three I'm doing well you
know I'm doing well so what do you know
ask for not even just like joke wise but
in a comedian what do you what do you
look for if like a comedian okay that
comedian has it I don't know I don't
know that's the crazy part about how I
flow I don't know what I'm looking for
until I see them and it could even be
rough around the edges at times but it's
just something about them and their
skillset you know one thing that's very
important for me is confidence
you know the commitment to the
microphone you could just see it in a
person you know and even like their
cadence and everything how they're
moving onstage you know they're they're
they're they're not playing one side of
the room to the other you know just
their mannerisms the way they take the
mic out of the stand and moves the stand
because there's none less you're using
the microphone as a prop
well I should say not the microphone but
the mic stand if you're using that as a
prop that's one thing but other than
that move that Joker out of the way it
looks like you you know you're doing
time up there with a bar so you know I
just watched for things like that and of
course originality
I mean understood that there's topics
there's topics mm-hmm that you know
everybody you know talk talk about
similar topics but who who does it
better you know I mean who can do it who
can really do make it happen better to
do it better you know I met Barry Katz
up in Montreal
yeah it's hot yeah let drink it up you
mayn't met Ben and he
yeah that if you know and that's is
definitely the podcast very and it was a
lot of fun hey Barry you just like a hot
draft yeah you guys probably a lot of
just rolling paddle on a lot of history
I mean come on crossing paths my office
was around the corner from his comedy
club in Greenwich Village oh yeah I used
to cross paths all the time on my way to
the path to travel the path train yet a
passage is if there's a path train that
runs between New York and New Jersey
okay
it's like the cheaper way as opposed to
the the New Jersey Transit truck God
show about two different ways but one
has like 50 stops and the other one has
like five stops right yeah great thing
that's crazy well Barry said that he's
been able to like shake someone's hand
and just tell okay this is the person he
said that was him for Chappelle like
when he met Chappelle and shook his hand
he could just see like the universe in
his eye
I do you have you ever had a similar
experience and only Barry with Jason
[Laughter]
[Music]
experience like you just instantly I
don't know yeah yeah yeah I mean even
even with David you know even with David
Barry was working with David and but
when we put Dave on on def Comedy Jam I
guess he was probably 18 years old and
you could see it then you know and even
like with today's you know the
sensational Tiffany Haddish right you
know what I'm saying I put Tiffany on
def Comedy Jam in oh seven that's ten
years ago you can see it same Tiffany
today really he's just you know refined
but more than anything boy Bernie Mac
move Bernie when I first saw Bernie I
actually saw him here in Atlanta
Bernie's from Chicago but when I first
saw him he just had it you you just knew
it and and Bill Bellamy he's another one
who I
basically took bill from you know the
beginning but we treated him like he was
a star before he became a star because
you could see that he had what it took
to make it so yeah anything is others
that you think may have it on the
challenge side but their character is
ridiculous you don't want to mess with
them because you know they're given
craft services problems they're given
wardrobe problems you know who wants to
be around you know an elephant in the
room nor the ego exactly so you know you
have that other side to it and I pretty
much move on from those type of
characters got to keep the common touch
I always say I mean that's one of the
things I don't know if you read any of
my BIOS or something but common sex is
one of the things I read a few things
well that's one of the things that do
work with me when I was like 11 years
old my god finally said to me you know
whatever you do in life you know you
could walk with kings and queens but
don't you ever lose the common touch did
I know I was gonna have the kings of
comedy and the queens of comedy before
they became kings and queens def Comedy
Jam built that you know and I'm proud to
say that I'm here right now talking to
you man that's how I say that give the
intro okay yeah you know - yeah it's
Seton Hall yeah sure it is yeah back in
the dizzay yeah man we have wax actually
yeah we used to play wax LPS
Wow LPS and 45 yeah you've always been
around creativity and whether it's music
you're watching all my life yeah all my
life my uncle what is in the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame mm-hmm you know there
was a singing group in the 50s called
the platters and Tony Williams he was
the lead singer and
that's how it really kind of started
with everybody in my family my dad he
was managing groups and my mom was
working at a record company my brothers
had a band and here I was this little
kid that was just being you know dragged
around to places like the world famous
Apollo Theater my parents just every
Wednesday every Sunday they were at the
Apollo then we would go up to my aunts
and uncles house up in Harlem you know
and it's crazy because now I'm back at
the Apollo's curative comedy man she was
late it's like renewed and when I tell
you that I saw Jackie moms Mabley
perform I saw Jackie moms Mabley perform
and then I end up presenting her into
the Apollo walk of fame is one of the
first non musical performers along with
Richard Pryor and Redd Foxx so it's um
this journey that I've been on yeah it's
crazy but laughs mom's laugh tracks we
premiere on January 3rd on truTV at 11
o'clock this is just like the bob sumner
journey continues man it's a little
documentary coming up in 2018 based on
who was bob sumner really at the birth
of deaf d EF you know how all of this
stuff happened prior to that big show
Wow yeah a good time right now yeah and
even mob and laughs mob is like more of
Bob's bet that's what they said meaning
basically that came as I always sleep
with the minor technology is what it is
but if you watch my show laughs moms we
got next on the aspire Network you know
they would always clown me because I
keep a pad with me either - yeah and I
keep you know I had a pad next to my bed
one night something just hit me where I
felt like I needed to create the next
thing for the next generation and I had
already you know did everything I can
do with Def Jam and now everybody's
trying to figure it out where again the
formula that I have I do have it figured
out but how do I present more of Bob's
best let me create this little like
you've had the lynch mob and this that
and the other let me just create some
real cool [ __ ] and call it the last mom
laughing mobbin is like a family more of
Bob's best as the afternoon it's all
good so it's been a work in progress I
partnered with Paul Reiser's old manager
Arthur Spivak who made some moves out in
Los Angeles and I told him what I wanted
to do and he wanted to get back into the
you know into the business he had kind
of like retired from the business and he
was big in the music industry as well so
you know we have have had this thing and
it's been it's been a spinner of a road
it's been a it's been rocky at times you
know a lot of people have given up on us
but again I've built too many careers to
say I'm no longer in this business and
no long and no longer being a major
player in the business that's not
happening and when people saw def Comedy
Jam 25 it was pretty much written right
there bro yeah yeah that a man it is I
could I could I could show you better
than I could tell you yeah yeah we're
people starting to say that you were
like just kind of like a one-trick pony
and like you were kind of out of the
game no not necessarily
but the thing is I I'm in the lab and
when you don't see me like I only deal
with quality things that's why I do the
Apollo comedy club you know the Apollo I
do the American Black Film Festival
comedy wings competition I do Alonzo
Mourning's events for his foundation you
know it's all hot stuff I just finished
doing the Soul Train Music cruise you
know going to a Cozumel and all that
stuff I'm into just hot stuff I'm
getting ready to partner with Tito's
handmade vodka and we're bringing
something back to a North New Jersey
call jazz and jokes which is gonna be
really cool for number of years I did a
thing called laugh mob on Sunset at the
world-famous Comedy Store and then I was
down on National Harbor and DC before it
became with it what it is now we did
something down there that was really
really hot
I just like to Dibble and dabble in
stuff that has flavor hmm like laughs
mobs
laughs trash that's me my thing you know
and what a common thread is is you
always root for the underdog it's all
about showcasing that untapped talent
listen you have to start somewhere
and I mean when I look at Craig
Robertson Deon Cole Mike Epps JB Smoove
Tracy Morgan Sheryl Underwood I mean I
remember Cheryl drove from California to
Orange New Jersey it was it was on
unsung she actually had somebody like
drive with her to perform and for me you
know in the rest is history
so yeah it's all about the underdog it's
all about the underdog and it's also
about not forgetting like a Theon
Crockett and DL Hughley two guys who I'm
very proud of in particular these guys
always when they see me they say this
thing that I said to them years ago and
it's don't ever let me see you eat pizza
with a fork I mean it's one thing if you
have the pan pizza that Hardee's and you
got it but I'm talking about that fourth
you know there's a google in third on
the corner in the village you know that
crazy
fold it up and eat it man you know you
have these guys now they make it in
Hollywood and now they need a little bit
in a knife and a fork and he's sitting
over in the corner eating the pizza like
a straight-up chump you know what I mean
that's not what it's all about it's
about not forgetting where you come from
you look at work and that a man just
grind that's how you appreciate you
you preciate it when you put it in man
when you put the time in and and even
like you never know when i'ma pop into a
comedy role and you have to treat a room
whether it's ten people in the room or
hundred people in the room or a thousand
people in the room every show is like
you never know who's there I mean I've
been in rooms in LA where it was like
all of the hot casting agents and
everybody in this room but it ain't but
like 15 of us in the room but don't be
talking about security the security did
a great job keeping people out of here
nobody want to hear those type of jokes
when we're here really to see you you do
something yeah yeah and with how comedy
and pretty much I mean how the world is
more interconnected now is it necessary
do you think in your opinion to move to
like an LA or New York to kind of get
that exposure because I'm in the
delusion I can just stay here in Atlanta
and then it'll gravitate well I believe
that you can stay within your your
comfort zone but get out of it sometimes
you know I mean have a plan and you know
when people take vacations and stuff if
you're really trying to win in this game
make your vacation a trip to New York
have some contacts that you develop here
up there and it's not always about the
money neither it's about getting you
know getting getting that getting
getting those chops you know and LA is
LA New York is New York I mean not
sounding biased but I do know that New
York is like you could really grind it
out there and make probably a couple
more dollars even if even though it's
not really about the money it does help
to make a couple dollars if you if you
have 15 minutes you can you could do
three sets a night somewhere and get
$200 you know you do that three four
times a week
make it eight eight eight hundred you
know yeah I mean it fluctuates but you
could do that la is a different story
but at the same time it's about that
grind and it's about even here creating
a room that you could work out are you
and a group of people because stage
there's nothing like stage time that's
how you get better
boom and you mentioned you ran across
Bernie Mac the first time here in
Atlanta yeah and I guess back when all
this was happening and you start we're
starting this Def Jam what was what was
the what was kind of the comedy scene
like back then then was it really a a
big comedy scene it was like really
underground I mean you had the
mainstream clubs and you had some
african-american comedians in those
clubs like Jimmy JJ Walker Mario Joyner
Michael Winslow
you know these type of guys but it
wasn't really no Bernie Max and no Steve
Harvey's that wasn't really happening so
we were able to change the game like
laughs mobs laugh tracks that's coming -
uh yeah - Joe yeah it's gonna be truTV
or January 3rd at 11:30 a.m.
directly after Impractical Jokers I
believe so that's a nice lead oh that is
a nice lead-in what is it llantas kind
of place in comedy history Alanna has
always been very special to me as have
Chicago in DC you know I could I can
actually say those those cities have
been very very integral to what I've
been doing and like Atlanta on the DEF
gem 25th Sheryl Underwood made mention
of the peppermint there was a spot that
I had up in
New York New Jersey actually where Bill
Bellamy was my host and my caps they
were my main host but anybody my host
tracing my host Chapelle my toes under
late Monteria IV who was a great friend
of mine and a great MC he would hold so
many people and the show was like so hot
that I bought the show to Atlanta okay
the same show the same time 10 o'clock
on a Thursday night I had him running
simultaneously I would come down to
Atlanta one week then I would be up in a
Jersey the next week it was so cool and
the reason I did it here is because it
was so many doggone comedians this was a
weekly show so I would have a host and
three comedians on every Thursday in
Jersey and in Atlanta so Atlanta means a
whole lot to me and I mean I'm talking
about the earthquakes and the Bruce
bruises and the doodoo Browns and the
Chris duckers these guys were you know
they were here you know Don DC Kerry you
know a lot of love Samoa Monique was
here at the time yeah
where was that show at it used to be at
the underground right at underground the
place was called Teddy's live oh and it
was all that underground every Thursday
night mm-hmm
yeah peppermint is legend Chris Charles
was the host yeah the peppermint is
legendary I've heard legends oxtails
actually oh okay ice tales and in peach
cobbler yeah I didn't I didn't really
mess with the chitlins too much but and
the the celebrities and the party like
500 people and you're turning people
away a lot of celebrities used to just
pop in there I mean the Knicks the Nets
you know at the time the Knicks in the
Nets with like popping you know they had
great teams as where the UH the Giants
and they were all they will always come
in and just hang out you know any any
given you might see Charles Oakley over
there you see
Lawrence Taylor over there Derrick
Coleman and Kenny Anderson and here
comes Naughty by Nature and Queen
Latifah and Wendy Williams and Shaquille
O'Neal that was the peppermint bra
it was crazy you hear me a lot of people
Jaheim might be onstage singing and Joe
the you know the artist Joe and Jessica
times and this was before the comedy
show with Bill Bellamy or Mike Epps and
then the Wayans brothers might be
sitting in the audience or Chris Rock
might do a couple minutes into place it
was like really wow it was a WoW moment
every Friday I mean every Thursday night
and you've you've been doing shows
before even like peppermint and putting
shows together there was a there was a
little spot in North called terminal D
then we really kicked off for me yeah
you know it was interesting because I
actually didn't even have a radio in my
car because it didn't make sense to have
one because after the third time it was
gone
this is stolen just used it was like I
was really grinding it out trying to
make it happen and iris you know iris we
just have equalizers and new cars and
stuff I risked all that for comedy for
my love for comedy so I didn't have a
radio in my in my Granada oh you mean my
solder you sold it her even you risked
it I risk having I did I just went
without I went without because I was
gonna have to go without every Tuesday
because they was like squat nor me and I
didn't really have an alarm anything oh
no it was just you know I just went on
the tan that was a moment in time I just
had a flashback
on on he's gonna look I want yeah yeah
but those are those are the moments were
looking for though yeah good times over
that's that is we started like doing
comedy this guy Antoine Mathis who I
grew up with he was doing stand-up
comedy and that's that's what gave me
the the bug to like who
these rooms and stuff hmm and then a lot
of the more you know you know urban
style comics they really didn't get an
opportunity to get into those veins main
rooms because you know they couldn't get
on the early show so they would stand in
line and get these numbers and about
time they got on stage it was like 2:00
in the morning so I wanted to develop a
place so that was terminal D it was
really cool and then I went to another
place called Club 88 stayed there for a
minute and then it was the birth of the
peppermint what what are some of the big
mistakes you're set because I produce a
weekly show here in Atlanta as well and
you've been able to create such
successful shows what are so maybe tips
you have for show producers to help
elevate the show for one trying to keep
up with the quality hmm with a weekly
show it's hard yeah you almost want to
have a hot-ass monthly show that people
really look forward to and you could
really stack the lineup the right way
because you know other than that you
basically just have an open mic you know
I mean and that those are you know over
mics are very very cool but you know you
you do want to be able to have a show
where you can one day take it from a
little you know club lounge into a
theater
whether it's a 500 cedar or 1500 cedar
so and then it's about giving
opportunity to the comedians who are
really putting in the work and aren't
just guys that's coming through there
just so they could try to sell their
DVDs and stuff you know that's kind of
corny you know and you have to really
utilize that space to build build your
craft if you are the standup
you know what I mean tape your tape you
know videotape and audiotape your
sessions and you know just get out there
and also you know develop your point of
view
if you're you know thinking about
getting into sketch create some original
characters as well as some you know
impressions of others you know just try
to separate yourself from the rest and
don't be too cliquish I mean it's cool
to have you know your little squad but
don't you know kind of be your own
person so you don't develop a style of
someone else's yeah a line you said last
night at the at the show you made the
line the science of the stage you said I
don't know if you remember even saying
it but you just said the science of the
stage and that just resonated with me
yeah and just yes you yeah it's the
science of the stage no know why you're
there and everybody's there for
different reasons but know why you're
there
don't waste the audience time don't
waste your time know why you're there
and commit to the science of the stage
you know it's it's when you get up on
that joint it's all mental it's all
mental for eight minutes or more eight
minutes is a long time
here you can bomb for eight minutes this
is the bomb three men yeah I could
really feel where somebody's going
really early in the game really early in
the game but again that's why I really
don't like to look at a footage I really
like to be right there yes I like to be
like I'm that big light I'm that shining
light yeah and I mean we watched the
other day at somebody who's a vet
fumbled yeah you don't say it then came
back the next night and Rob because they
knew they came but it's all about
preparation and if I'm in your building
it's serious and that's what I was
saying don't don't ever underestimate
who's in that club or any given night
that's why I've been in the club the
past two nights I wasn't even worried
about like a taping I was like Oh Bob
summers in Atlanta I was like where is
he gonna be okay well that's that's
where I'm gonna be yeah
I don't even know how that even happens
but I think like you said before I'm all
about the underdog yeah yummy I want to
see people win nothing nothing makes me
feel better than to see a comedian go
from the outhouse to depend on series
you know and when I say comedian I take
that serious you know there's a lot of
comics out here it's very few comedians
and there is a difference there's a
difference a comic works within a box a
comedian can look at the room and know
exactly what to say and don't have to
change their say just know the cadence
know how to how to pick the room a comic
comic control choke straight up choke
it's a lot of comics I've seen them from
you watching legitimately the Great's in
comedy are is there like a common thread
between all of them that makes them so
effective or was it's according to what
you would say are great because they
it's some people that think that the cut
the greats and they're not really the
greats
I mean like a Bernie Mac Dave Chappelle
oh yeah
those are the great yes yeah there's a
show buyers see in the time in the
comment thread amongst all you guys you
I never forget when you and Colin was
playing at that room that night
Gary Carlin not my puppet I was doing a
I mean I mean point-blank these guys
have a confidence level that goes with
their experience on stage and all of
those guys aren't guys that did comedy
for a couple months then stopped these
guys was in the club's every night you
know I'm saying so yeah that's the
common thread they work for what they're
getting right now mmm bling this is fat
facts you know and watching them work
the stage do you find those kind of
comedians are more improvisational on
stage or is it more scripted it's more
knowledgeable knowledgeable what do I
mean by that you're right these guys
keep up with current events all those
guys that we just talked about they hit
smart as hell you know what I'm saying
and that's that they may keep up with
what's happening now in a in a flipping
they flip everything you know they don't
always have to just do jokes about the
guy that's in the Oval Office right now
you know they talk about a whole lot of
other things and that's that's the
beauty of all of them you know more than
anything else they they just don't if
they know that they have a tour coming
they go to the hole-in-the-wall clubs
and they work their stuff out some guys
just same script same script same script
these guys don't have the same script I
mean David just did three Netflix
specials with all different material for
90 minutes you know saying unbelievable
he'll go into a room and actually do
three hours of just improvisational
stuff because I mm-hmm everybody has
different skill sets cuz I've heard
Chris Rock is more like by the book like
every line he is pretty much like
rehearsed and like has it written out
almost like a book
and it's be tight oh yeah about time
he'd take it out there and under onto
that big stage yeah it's tight you know
you didn't is you know kev-kev goes
about it his way
you know I mean he comes from a
different school but he's hey what is
that school he comes from it's
preparation is more with a collective
group you know I mean from what I see he
handles his his stand-up just like it's
a sitcom or whatever you know what I'm
saying they all come together and they
they're out there out in the clubs to
picking up one things and seeing what
what's going on I mean he's perfected
his is his lane yeah so proud of him
proud of him
does that make you feel a different way
about some eyes material if somebody
else is writing it no no no same thing
with hip-hop music and every rapper
ain't right his lines or her line you
know saying it is what it is
somebody else got to get a check yeah
that's why they have publishers and
things you know what is it about comedy
and I've noticed just then you bringing
up Def Jam and you want to give more
opportunities for black comedians what
is it up not necessarily black comedians
oh you're just saying the club's oh yeah
oh okay
in the Def Jam that's why it's about
that time in like comedies because there
were not nothing many opportunities and
you wanted to blaze that new trails no
doubt about there so even now in in our
current times it almost seems like
comedy clubs and churches are two things
that are still segregated more than most
kind of maybe venues I don't know if you
any insight under maybe why you think
that is I don't even understand what why
I don't understand why and it doesn't
affect me because I've never been one
that but I've always been like a a
people person you know I I just I just
always been one that
was all about civil rights and civil
rights didn't have no color hmm you know
what I'm saying yeah and so that that
that's that's a problem for them to fix
oh good I've just noticed them doing
comedy because I'll do both
I'll do all rooms like whenever wherever
how him do it well so me appreciate that
so I don't I mean again we we don't we
don't have those answers we've got we
won't have those answers but that just
go to show you that it it's everywhere
yeah
it's not and it's not just churches in
comedy clubs you know I mean it's it's
in restaurants at least they're laughing
about the boycott well before I get you
out of here there is there's one thing I
always ask my guests on here mm-hmm
and it's usually yes on yeah oh you're
good at just repeating that's marketing
I guess you just burn it to the brain
you have to burn it in the brain because
I'm gonna tell you this right now huh on
Wednesday January 3rd right we have this
show coming the truTV called laugh mobs
laugh track hosted by sight for sounds
and it's really gonna flip comedy on so
I heard this yes yes it's really hot I
mean yeah it's really really hot so oh
yeah man yeah you're right so that's
that's what's that man that's what's up
yeah and we're here at first on hot
brass you know hot mess yeah so what I
love to ask comedians is a story of
getting booed on stage and just an epic
failure they've had because I talk about
the success but you're not anywhere
without the teacher of failure mm-hmm so
this can be your most epic failure or
one you've seen yeah I mean I'm not a
comedian so but even Justin I mean no
I'm not I'm not a comedian and epic
failures and stuff no I used to watch
comedians really get like you come to
salads you know I mean I have really
seen Tomatoes
[Music]
lettuce cabbage onions potatoes bottles
I saw a guy get a garbage can throw that
mean this is all you know it's crazy but
you just have to be prepared for you
know your the environment that you get
on you know it's like every stage isn't
always the right stage you know so again
I mean I've had comedians who are really
well known now really struggle but not
give up one comedian in particular I had
him come on I used to do this jazz club
and I used to throw a comedian on every
now and then and this guy he was really
not doing well so you know instead of
him like really like getting the message
to get offstage you start hearing the
pianist tink tink Linda you don't like a
ward show when they start your speech
there yeah oh man it was hilarious and
now this guy's a big star so oh really
yeah so things happen oh can you Duvall
- that is no I can't
no but I've one thing I can tell you
though is yeah that one January
well we'll be sure to tune into that on
what channel truTV's right UTV what's
yeah after Impractical Jokers so lately
yeah man they don't know what they're
getting into yes really it's gonna be
great in wait until I mean this this
first season I know it's gonna be really
cool mm-hmm but I'm looking forward to
the next season which I'm sure there'll
be one because the shows that dope I
never forget when def Comedy Jam the
first season I call it Bernie Mac stir
it like coffee season because people
always forget like you automatically
think about I ain't scared you mother
you know right that came the second
season
as did Chris Tucker and some others the
first season was to Sterilite and that
Def Jam was based off the peppermint
room peppermint lounge I mean it was it
was like the vibe was between their
uptown comedy club and in Harlem had
that vibe comedy act theater you know
that was a few rooms only a few rooms
that was mopping back then comedy
connection in Greenbelt Maryland Chris
Thomas used to have a spot over there on
Sunday nights that was popping you know
then all jokes aside came a little later
than you had Miami nights down in Miami
Studio 183 so it's it's been like a you
know a snowball effect would stand-up
comedy but now it's you know it's crazy
because I remember when we came up
Comedy Jam named def Comedy Jam it was
just something to happen you know and
now you have my uncle Leroy's Comedy Jam
you know you gonna Joe's car watch
Comedy Jam it's like honey jam became
something that just happened because we
had a label called Def Jam
do you think we're going through another
comedy boom yeah we're going to a comedy
boom and I think but if the comedy boom
is really you know laughs mobs laugh
track I mean I can't help I mean it's
like it's that it's that hot of a shot
yeah man it comes on truTV on January
3rd well hopefully I'm gonna call it on
a season two will see what I hate hey
listen I can't promise it to you but I
can maybe give you a pinkie swear I
don't know no nah but you was uh you
definitely um I've been talking about
you I've been talking about you but
again we're going to the lab and see
what we come up with and at the end of
the day you know the network makes the
final decision right was it a B OSS you
know ba I gotcha gotcha
I'm the mo BB what are you just talking
about me as an extreme player
jinan er so yeah before we get out of
here is there anything else you want the
world to know I want the world to know
and he thinks I'm gonna talk about
laughs mobs laughs tracks on truTV
that's not what i'ma talk about that
it's coming on January 3rd at 11 p.m.
I'm not really going to talk about how
it's the hottest show and you know I
just want to again thank everybody who
have hung in there with me over all my
years in this business and if anybody
wants to uh howl at me it's bob dot
Sumner and Instagram and Bob something
224 I have another Instagram yeah I
don't know how that happened but then I
have like a bob sumner comedy spot on
Facebook and then I have my regular page
but that's for you know just my folks
but the comedian's could go on the other
page and I have a bob sumner
Entertainment Group page there's a
laughs mom page there's a is just follow
you know just follow me man follow what
I'm doing and there's a whole lot have a
Saturday night comedy show that we do
monthly in a Jersey South Jersey jazz
and jokes is poppin now the Apollo
comedy club we have the comedy wings
competition that's going on right now
people can um submit to that and you
know just uh keep loving living laughing
because love is and you know preciate
you bruh Thank You uncle Bob maybe her
being on hot breath yeah I was just
doing
[Music]
high breath